hello my name is toby astle and i am
perkin elmer's global market manager for
cannabis and hemp it's a pleasure to be
with you today and thank you to lab
roots for the speaking opportunity
today i'd like to chat about simplifying
pesticide and microtoxin testing
workflows with full sample preparation
and data management automation
just a brief agenda for today's talk
firstly i'd like to speak to some
details about cannabis and cbd
and then i'd like to emphasize the
importance for testing the product i'd
also like to then expand on where we see
experimental error introduced into these
workflows and finally conclude what we
can do to mitigate these errors using
automation
[Music]
as we know cannabis is a complex
material to handle but as we see
increasing legal markets open up around
the globe we're excited to work with
scientists to make sure that
each chemical assay is performed
confidently and the correct data is
collected
we know that the material has a wide
number of constituents in it such as
cannabinoids terpenes chlorophyll and
waxes
and this is also compounded by the
additional materials used to make some
of the final products you see here
and what we
now appreciate is that the need to test
cannabis for consumer safety is
paramount
if we look at some data published by
california the department of bureau of
cannabis control we see that pesticides
are one of the highest
reasons
batches fail in the testing environment
making sure labs have
resources and options for testing both
pesticides and micro toxins successfully
will be critical in ensuring consumer
safety
we can also look at the cbd
industry and we have seen data to show
that a number of cbd products are also
showing presence of pesticides and
microtoxins above the action limits
collectively we want to work together
with the industry to improve the
workflows and reduce the number of
failed batches
[Music]
so what i'd like to focus in on today
are two areas that are important for all
laboratories not just cannabis and hemp
one is sample preparation and
optimizing the sample prep preparation
to be the most efficient
and also data quality and data control
as we do not want to reduce
preparation time at the sacrifice of
poor data quality
so looking at this together combined
with the quantitative assay at the end
is critical for a verifiable method for
these industries
but what we can take note of is that for
all laboratories
we see a significant amount of time and
also error
occur in sample processing and sample
preparation
we know that each analyst is going to
behave and perform differently
this
inherently has an associated
experimental error with it and depending
on the day or the analyst that can be
considerable
when it comes to assays such as the
pesticide and microtoxin assay where
we're looking at parts per billion
even the small amount of error at the
beginning can have significant
consequences in the final result
[Music]
let's take a look at california as a
case study to see and understand where
some of this experimental error can come
from
if we look at the pesticide and
microtoxin testing requirements labs
need to source 66 pesticides and 5
microtoxin standards
these often come from a handful of
suppliers
they also need to work with suppliers
for the internal standards and the
consumables
for the method this is a very cumbersome
process and leads to quite a lot of
inefficiencies in managing the workflow
in the lab
when it comes to preparing the
calibration standards and the quality
control standards we also see a very
laborious process on the bench
we see the stock solution be mixed and
then subsequent dilutions for each of
the calibration curve points
this inherently also can contribute
error systematically if it is not
performed correctly
the perkin arm application team
appreciated this and realized that it
was not ideal so we looked at the
workflow very closely to see what we
could do differently to improve
throughput and data quality
and what the result was was the launch
of a pre-formatted
certified reference material reagent kit
which carries an iso 17034
certification
and includes calibration vials broken
down into eight points each having 77
pesticides and 5 microtoxins in each
calibration
bile we also included quality control
standards and internal standards
[Music]
and what this results in is offering
labs a more efficient option for their
workflow
it starts by having just one part number
to order and manage
and all of the required reagents and
consumables now come in this part number
when it comes to the bench level it's
very straightforward we just take the
vial out of the freezer let it come to
room temperature and inject it into the
lc vial for the instant
calibration
this can be used across all matrices
and is continually being evaluated to
meet all the regulatory pesticide
testing needs
and looking at the time saving
specifically from this reagent kit we
looked at the legacy workflow of what i
mentioned earlier
and the cumbersome process of preparing
multiple calibration and internal and
quality control standards
with the kit these steps are now removed
saving labs up to 90 minutes per day
which they can be
used
to allocate those stuff to more
appropriate tasks such as data review
[Music]
understanding that quality control is
essential
and
needed across all pesticide and
microtoxin labs we also included the
quality control standards in the kit
specifically
the continuing calibration verification
vial or ccv
the icv the initial calibration
verification which comes from a second
manufactured lot for iso and state
compliance
and lastly the laboratory control sample
or lcs
these are part of a rigorous qms
workflow for any busy compliance lab
[Music]
what we also appreciated was that
cannabis
samples and cannabis matrix types have a
significant influence on the performance
in the instrument
what we see here are five different
cannabis and cbd samples of five
different matrices having various
degrees of iron suppression in the mass
spectrometer
to mitigate and improve the data quality
for this test we've now included
internal standards into the same reagent
kit
we include 30 internal standards that
allow you to now quantitate very low
level pesticide and microtoxin residues
in a challenging cannabis matrix
[Music]
being able to source the internal
standards at the same time as the
calibration standards also means the lab
can offer or work with much more
efficient processes
and the result for this kit is being
able to take
reagents out of the box and produce an
eight point linear calibration curve
quantitation
together with perkinomirs pesticide and
microtoxin methodology and the qci-420
lcm sms there is now a much more
confident workflow for cannabis and hemp
laboratories
to make sure that this workflow is
proven to work in high volume compliance
settings
we took part in the emerald proficiency
test
earlier this year passing
for pesticides and micro toxin
quantitation giving us the full
confidence that this workflow is viable
in cannabis and hemp compliance testing
labs
so what i'd like to talk to now is
taking it further and adding automation
to this workflow we see labs now running
upwards of
one two thousand samples a month
and automation has been seen to add
efficiencies across all indices and now
can be adopted for cannabis and hemp
laboratories
automation improves the compliance from
seat sale and reduces or removes some of
the repetitive steps
while also improving reproducibility it
also allows the lab to allocate the
staff to do more higher value tasks
whilst the technology and the automation
performs the mundane sample preparation
steps
what we've been able to do is develop a
specific workflow called qs works 420
automation
which includes the micro balance the
janus 420 sample preparation platform
the q site 420 lcm sms and finally
simplicity lab 420 a cloud based
software that communicates and
transports data
across the entire workflow
presenting it in a certificate of
analysis or even to metric in the
compliance environment if needed
[Music]
let's take a look now specifically at
the janus 420 this is the first fully
automated sample preparation platform
for cannabis and pesticide and
microtoxin testing
what we see here is that there are
technologies to vortex
centrifuge
mix
filter
and transfer liquid and standards across
the workflow
the final result is the flower sample at
the beginning
is then converted to being in a two
milliliter hplc vial that can go
straight on the mass spectrometer
[Music]
but what we wanted to be very
cautious of was replacing technology or
a manual workflow that
has very high
performance requirements
what we were able to do
is compare the
and evaluate the manual and the
automated workflow and found the
automated workflow to have equivalent or
better performance than the manual
workflow
this gives us the confidence that these
automation workflows are
viable and appropriate in the cannabis
testing environment
what we were able to do
is confirm that we can prepare 48
cannabis samples in less than two hours
a similar task by labs taking upwards of
four to five hours this also gives the
benefit that the lab can
allocate those
important personnel stuff to other tasks
while the sample preparation is being
done
[Music]
to conclude furukanama is excited to
offer you the widest
widest breadth in portfolio workflow
solutions
it starts with the sample preparation
from the omni homogenizes goes to the
reagents and the sample preparation
platform i showed
and lastly finishing with our mass
spectrometry portfolio of the q site and
the simplicity lab 420 software that
connects it all together
i encourage you all to check out our
social media channels to stay current
with the industry updates and
application literature you can find us
on
twitter
linkedin and instagram
and lastly i'd like to say we are
excited to work with all cannabis and
hemp labs globally and bring technology
like the one pesticide reagent kit and
the janus 420 qs works automation
workflow to labs to improve their
throughput and also improve their data
quality
please don't hesitate to reach out to me
after this presentation as i would love
to answer any questions you may have
thanks for that and take care bye bye
for now